in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Michael
and Sarah are with us hey how are you
how you doing
better than I deserve merry Christmas to
you too where do you guys live we live
in Tulsa Oklahoma and all the way to
Nashville to do a debt-free scream yes a
nine-hour Drive today Oh with what a
toddler
that's an 18-hour driver makes a double
it's a double factor okay Wow
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes there how much have you paid
off in the past two years we paid off
forty-one thousand and then we've cash
flowed an additional 18,000 during that
period of time as well whoa 18,000 for
what thirteen thousand was for a ser to
go back to school and then another 5,000
was for home renovations which we
actually ended up selling that house and
so we had to do it in order to sell the
house gotcha
making what kind of money during that
two years um I have a couple sources of
income because you know just trying to
move everything along as quick as
possible but between the three that I
have basically mid-50s to high 50s okay
so in the $50,000 range okay and that's
pretty impressive you guys have lived on
beans and rice yes you really have I
mean nothing nothing did you sell
something in this town yeah that's what
helped okay the Varian was selling our
house and we sold the house that knocked
off basically the last half of the debt
okay twenty thousand exactly okay about
20 over the first two years and then
again at the very end just two months
ago we sold the house and knocked off
the last 20 of the debt gotcha and where
are you living my parents right now we
are okay but that's not long-term by any
means what's the plan yeah we love you
guys know we we're looking into a rental
because I honestly we'd really like to
save up cash and pay cash for our next
house okay but at this point you know
what happened was our household so fast
it literally sold before we technically
had it on the market we just had a sign
in our yard that's it coming soon and so
there's no way we could find a place in
time we don't want to rush that type of
decision so um basically our plan is
after the holidays we're gonna really
start looking heavily for a rental yeah
okay get your own place set back up yeah
and then and then start the process of
saving towards the next house yes
they're good for you tell me your story
what happened two years ago that puts
you guys on this
so it actually started about three to
three and a half years ago um my degree
is personal financial planning and so I
came out of school and I really wanted
to put what I learned to practice and
particularly in a church setting and so
I went to my pastor and at the time and
I asked him if you know if you had any
suggestions and how I could use that as
far as ministry was concerned and he
gave me your name so I started doing a
lot of research of course and the first
thing I found out was everything I
learned in school was the exact opposite
of what you teach basically in school I
was taught how to manage debt and how to
you know make people leverage their you
know their money to where they can live
the most extravagant lifestyle they want
to live and then I heard the true
biblical you know knowledge coming from
what your lessons taught and I knew
immediately okay this is what I need to
start teaching Wow so we I immediately
started teaching that and that's when we
kind of jumped into it
we've coordinated a total of six classes
so thank you
absolutely we love it but what happened
is after our first class coordinating we
both lost our income for over about a
six month period of time whoa and took
us about a year to recover from that so
it was really the grace of God that we
didn't go into any further debt during
that period of time but it was kind of
survival mode so once we got back on our
feet which is about two years ago that's
when we really started going crazy on
the debt okay so now that we get our
jobs back here we go yeah that makes
sense
okay well congratulations how's it feel
thank you it feels absolutely amazing I
I told my wife whenever I walked into
work the next day
it was like a very spiritual feeling I
couldn't even explain but it was just it
was that debt that you know that bondage
being lifted off our lives and for some
reason was when I walked into work that
I could feel that you know as soon as I
walked in it was just this like I said
there was a very God moment I mean but
it's amazing having so much extra cash
right now of course we're living with
our parents right now so that makes it
even cheaper but you know it's just
amazing how much extra cash we have now
well they probably love having a
grandbaby around for the holidays they
do and they watch her for me while I go
to school so okay what are you studying
fashion design oh good for you
Thanks excellent very cool all right so
you're a financial counselor
professionally trained now trained by
Hard Knocks as well yeah and that's
familiar I know a guy like that and so
what is your counsel to people listening
right now on how you get out of debt I
would say it's quite a few things I mean
I wouldn't just say sums up into one
thing but probably the biggest is of
course just discipline and actually
following a budget and planning
I'd be I'm amazed at the number of
people that go through your program that
I've seen that succeed when they use
discipline they actually follow you know
along in a budget and they actually make
a plan versus the one that's that don't
succeed it's almost always just because
they don't have the discipline I mean
it's not a matter of them retaining or
understanding you know what you're
teaching it's a matter of them not being
willing to actually you know let the
rubber meet the road so to speak and and
go for it exactly and the other thing I
think is just it's the grace of God
honestly we this has been the toughest
time of our life going through this not
necessarily cuz a financial aspect but
we just had of course I told you about
the period of lost income but we also
lost my mom a year and a half ago to
breast breast cancer and it was a course
a very very difficult time for us but
you know it's one of those things that
all I can say is looking back it was
God's faithfulness that got us through
every step every month somehow someway
we are still chipping away in it and
then you know again here we are two
years later and completely done yeah
Sarah what do you say when people say
how did you get out of debt you know I
think for women the hardest thing
sometimes is embracing simple living I
know for me being in fashion design
school and just it's so easy in being a
mom like you want to accumulate material
things and so it's so easy to get
focused on those things and I think one
of the most freeing lessons I learned
was in embracing simple living there's
so much freedom to be found in that
because I realized those things that
were so important to me in the moment I
don't even remember what they were
and now our money's freed up to be able
to walk out the destiny that God has for
us and the plan that he has and that's
sorry that's the most frig thing to me I
love it
that's awesome very cool very well said
love it phenomenal phenomenal all right
and your daughter your toddler's name is
Millie so she's gonna scream with you
I'm hoping I'm wondering mercy that
she's over here it looks like she's in
good shape she's gonna try we tried we
had nine hours to practice yeah maybe
we'll see alright Michael and Sarah and
pretty Millie I love it and they paid
off forty-one thousand dollars in debt
and cash flowed eighteen thousand in the
last two years selling a house and
making $50,000 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
excellent excellent work very very well
done you guys would be so rich so fast
and be able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others